okay but I mean if I could quote from
your Wall Street Journal article that
you wrote plugged in your book you said
no this was being you're being sarcastic
you said I took America to war in Iraq
it was all me
yes okay so obviously a lot of people
didn't know that was sarcasm
seriously seriously I got a lot of
people saying thank you for finally
finally acknowledging Wow and I and I
said well that's a powerful stupid yeah
that that's extremely it we say it's a
stupid country but they never cease to
shock me I didn't want to hog the credit
I wanted to give a little to the
President of the United States but I
mean well okay but here's here's what
you also said and this is also your
being sorry
okay you say I had some help from a
delicious vice president Dick Cheney
there was George W Bush a gullible
president who wanted to avenge his
father then you say and don't forget the
neoconservatives who cherry picked
intelligence about a rat Iraq's weapons
of mass destruction and fed it to
reporters like me and then you say none
of these assertions happens to be true
the reason I might have some trouble
with your credibility is that I think
all these assertions are true
I think Dick Cheney is delicious I think
George Bush is gullible I think he was
trying to avenge his father
I think neo-cons did cherry-pick
intelligence why should I believe you if
I don't believe any of these assertions
because the information they got from
the intelligence community as opposed to
those who wanted to go to war every
administration has hawks and doves or
hawks and pragmatists but the
information they got was with high
confidence that Saddam Hussein had
biological and chemical weapons and
moderate conference confidence that he
did not yet have a nuclear weapon now if
you're the president of the vice
president in charge of securing the
country after 9/11 and you've had an
anthrax attack that has killed people
and shut down post office not by Iraq no
no no but if you've had all that and
you're responsible for the country and
your intelligence community says hey
this guy
really bad 17 UN resolutions complaining
about his lack of candor in his lack of
complying with the problem here they're
gonna believe that we all know he's a
bad guy but the world is full of bad
guys but I mean not all with WMD which
of course he didn't have okay you've
made that point for me I think the
soldiers I was covering made that point
yeah of course but and and look I take
your point when you say you were singled
out that's true
there you are hardly the only one first
of all you had editor's who printed your
stories there had the final say you had
by lines that you shared with other
people and somehow you're the only one
in the picture so I'm sympathetic to
that what I'm not so sympathetic to is
the idea that nobody else was saying we
shouldn't go to war people many people
were saying it and there were many many
articles about the people who didn't
want to go to war and why they didn't
want to go to war but that wasn't what I
was responsible for covering I I really
believe that there were a lot of people
who felt even if Saddam Hussein had WMD
we shouldn't go to war and there were
debates about in hindsight would you
have been more skeptical about it I
couldn't have been more skeptical I was
more skeptical I every time I got
information that contradicted something
we had reported I went back and did a
second story sometimes those articles in
the New York Times did scare a lot of
people well for good let me let me quote
one thing you you said Iraq could try to
disperse the biological agents by using
aircraft or unmanned drones the germs
could be dropped in a bomb or sprayed in
the air finally biological agents could
be delivered against civilian targets by
Iraqi age you all that could happen
monkeys could fly out my butt but you
know
to say but that at that moment it scared
people and of course there's a special
place where the New York Times has in
this which is you know for liberals the
New York Times this is the place that
was Nixon's nemesis had printed the
Pentagon Papers so when they say
something like this it carries a
different weight you under you
appreciate that absolutely but first of
all the New York Times was not alone
almost every paper in the country was
reporting this and network but beyond
that this information was coming from
the men and women who had gotten Osama
bin Laden right who understood that the
country was vulnerable to a biological
weapons attack I was relying on those
same sources they had never lied to me
they were usually right we had lots of
qualifiers in the story but how can we
not tell the American people the
information that the president is
getting that's the information he was
making is what I would say to this is
that one of the one of to me one of the
most fundamental flaws of this great
country great oh yes I'm saying it's a
great country but it has this
military-industrial complex
Eisenhower talked about it he was so
right they always want to go to war it's
one reason why we've been to war for a
vast majority of our history were always
in it with somebody and we kind of
depend on the Fourth Estate to call
[ __ ] on the military-industrial
complex because they are always trying
to do it
that's true but there are also people
who are not war mongers like Hillary
Clinton and the people who regiments oh
there were there was an overwhelming
vote in the Congress for this and
Democrats believe this intelligence -
including John Kerry who's now trying to
negotiate the Iran deal there was a
consensus and if that consensus was
wrong I think you can't blame either
reporters for reporting what the
consensus was or the intelligence
analysts who got it wrong though I
wanted to go back and say how did this
happen that's why I wrote the book how
did this happen how did they get it so
wrong but you have an obligation as a
reporter to do that that's what we've
stopped doing pretty much we have a
narrative now people lied
they lied people died but that's not
what happened it was worse than that the
intelligence community that has paid
billions of dollars a year 16 different
agencies totally got it wrong and I
don't know why people are more comforted
by the fact that with the notion that we
were lied to then that they got it wrong
and they could get it wrong again